I'm going to run for president United
States wow while the formal announcement
will be later in April in Bentonville uh
I wanted to make that'll be a real party
clear that to you Jonathan I am going to
be running and the reason uh as I've
traveled the country for six months I
hear people talk about the leadership of
our country and I'm convinced that
people want leaders that appeal to the
best of America and not simply appeal to
our worst instincts all right so he has
absolutely no shot but it is interesting
to see more people enter if I were a
betting man and I'm not my guess is Asa
Hutchinson doesn't even make it past the
first Republican primary now that being
said more candidates generally does seem
to be better for Donald Trump